these people are eating thousands of
calories of mcdonald's in a single
sitting
that's a pretty awful idea but do you
know what might be worse
eating mcdonald's food for an entire
year
how would it affect your body well on
today's episode
we're going to show you this is your
body on
eating mcdonald's for a year
what's your favorite meal at mcdonald's
let's say you get a big mac medium fries
and
don't forget about that coca-cola this
is a pretty average meal at mcdonald's
and it's over 1 000 calories which is
nearly half
of a person's daily calorie intake and
this is just one of your meals for this
challenge
we're going to have you eat breakfast
lunch dinner and you can't forget about
snacking
would your body be able to handle this
for an entire year
[Music]
hey we've all had weeks where we've
eaten nothing but fast food so your
first week of eating mcdonald's
shouldn't be too bad you might feel a
bit constipated
and gassy
[Music]
since you're not getting enough fiber in
your digestive system
and you'll start feeling more sluggish
and tired
you can try the grilled chicken and
salads but you'll quickly realize
they're not filling enough and all those
greasy fries and burgers are giving you
some slight heartburn but
it isn't so bad that you need to see a
doctor
so do you think you can keep eating like
this
okay you've been eating mcdonald's for a
couple of weeks now and you're starting
to get a bit
bored with your go-to items so you start
eating your way through the menu
chicken wraps breakfast sandwiches maybe
even a salad or two
but every time you choose a burger over
a salad here's what happens inside your
body
your pancreas will get an alert that
there are high fat and high carb meals
on the way
and release insulin the more frequently
you eat this stuff
the more your insulin levels will spike
going up and down which
could lead to diabetes but that's in the
future
right now you'll be dealing with more
acne than normal
this is due to the high amount of carbs
and higher blood sugar levels from
eating all this food
so you've been eating burgers fries
chicken nuggets and
whatever else is on the menu at
mcdonald's for half a year
this means you've been eating well above
the recommended number of daily calories
so
it's no surprise that you've put on some
pounds around your waist
this extra weight will put pressure on
your lungs and heart
even climbing up stairs could make you
out of breath
your cholesterol levels are incredibly
high and your arteries are at risk of
getting
blocked okay now your
year-long experiment is coming to an end
let's take a look at
what you've done you've spent about 5
400
on fast food
and consumed well over 3000 calories
every day
and oh man i don't even want to think
about how much weight you've gained
after all that you're probably
pre-diabetic
due to all the sugar you've consumed not
to mention the sodium
after your second meal of the day you
would have exceeded your recommended
maximum daily value of
2300 milligrams of sodium so you've lost
a lot of money gained a bunch of weight
and have a long list of health problems
this diet was a terrible idea
but luckily if you accept a challenge to
do this
mcdonald's does have some healthier
options for you and you can always
track the calories on the menu to help
you make better decisions
so if you decide to do this which we
don't recommend
you can spend your year eating grilled
chicken salads and
apple slices it would be hard to resist
those burgers but
it can be done okay so you
just barely survived this challenge what
about another one that's
less lethal like going vegan maybe well
we'll see what that challenge brings on
another episode of your body on